ja weil dann beginnen wir ich begrüße
sie sehr herzlich zum presseball koch
institut heute am dritten dezember 2020
wieder mit professor lothar wieler
präsident des robert koch instituts und
der rexroth leiterin des lagezentrums
wieder mit guten morgen meine damen und
herren
meine damen und herren die lage bleibt
weiterhin sehr angespannt in den letzten
wochen ist es durch die maßnahme zwar
gelungen die fallzahlen zu stabilisieren
das ist auch ein erster erfolg das
möchte ich auch sehr deutlich sagen denn
ohne diese maßnahmen wäre die situation
heute sehr viel schlimmer
dennoch es infizieren sich immer noch zu
viele menschen mit saas kopf zwei die
zahlen sind immer noch zu hoch sie
befinden sich auf einem plateau aber sie
sinken noch nicht spürbar
wir sehen dass die gesundheitsämter
zunehmend erschöpft sind sie schaffen es
zum beispiel nicht mehr zu ermitteln wo
sich die betroffenen angesteckt haben
wir sehen immer mehr ausbrüche in alten-
und pflegeheim es gelingt immer seltener
das virus aus diesen einrichtungen
herauszuhalten und die menschen dort zu
schützen
wir sehen das in einigen regionen auch
krankenhäuser an ihre belastungsgrenzen
stoßen dass dort operationen oder
behandlungen verschoben werden müssen
wir sehen auch dass die zahl der
schweren verläufe und der todesfälle von
woche zu woche steigt dabei das immer
erst mit einem gewissen zeitverzug
eintritt müssen wir hier auch mit vielen
weiteren rechnen
diese entwicklung ist leider nicht
überraschend es ist die entwicklung die
wir anhaltend bei hohen anhaltend hohen
fallzahlen befürchtet hatten
ich habe in den letzten wochen betont
dass wir die neuinfektionen auf einen
level auf ein niveau bringen müssen das
für gesundheitsämter krankenhäuser und
labore gut zu bewältigen ist
um dieses level zu erreichen meine damen
und herren muss die zahl der
neuinfektionen aber deutlich gesenkt
werden
ich hoffe sehr dass für diese trendwende
gemeinsam schaffen wir sind diesem virus
nicht hilflos ausgeliefert
mit 19 ist eine vermeidbare erkrankungen
wir können viele infektionen verhindern
ganz zentral sind dafür nach wie vor die
asl regeln abstand halten mindestens ein
meter fünfzig hygieneregeln beachten
dort wo das gegeben ist alltags masken
tragen und natürlich auch lüften bitte
beherzigen sie diese regeln immer und
überall am arbeitsplatz in der schule am
einkaufen und sie gelten auch zu hause
wenn zum beispiel der nachbar kurz
einmal vorbei kommt wir können uns mit
diesem virus prinzipiell überall
anstecken überall dort wo menschen
zusammenkommen
meine kollegin dr ute rexroth wird ihnen
die aktuelle entwicklungen nun im detail
vorstellen
sie ist erst den infektionsepidemiologie
und sie leitet den das lagezentrum am
robert koch institut for excel vielen
dank guten morgen auch von meiner seite
ich möchte ihnen jetzt eben die zahlen
darstellen wir letztes mal auch mit
seit beginn der pandemie haben wir also
bis heute bis zum 31 12 2020 um 0 uhr
insgesamt eine million 106 1789 mit 19
fälle ans lka übermittelt bekommen den
november über waren dass täglich
zwischen 11 und 23 1000 fällen und
gestern also bis heute 0 uhr waren es
noch mal 22.000 46 neue fälle die uns
übermittelt worden sind das sind ganz
ähnlich viele wie am mittwoch davor und
am vorletzten mittwoch
die fallzahlen sind also weiter auf
einem hohen niveau und sie sinken
deutschlandweit noch nicht wirklich
spürbar der sieben tages wert schwankt
seit wochen um die 1
er ist zuletzt etwas gefallen und liegt
aktuell bei 0,89 die entwicklung
unterscheidet sich jedoch je nach
bundesland und auch nach altersgruppen
und da möchte ich zunächst auf die
entwicklung in den verschiedenen
bundesländern eingehen wenn sie bitte
die grafik 1 1 blenden würden diese
zeigt die sieben tages incidents nach
bundesland die haben wir ihnen ja schon
mehrfach gezeigt und dort sehen wir also
die bundesweite 7 tages ins bett ins die
liegt jetzt bei 134 fällen je 100.000
einwohner
und die hat sich in den letzten wochen
nur ganz wenig verändert ist klein
bisschen zurückgegangen aber nur ganz
wenig sie sehen allerdings an den bunten
linien drum rum dass sich die
entwicklung in den bundesländern doch
deutlich unterscheidet wir können sehen
dass stadtstaaten wie berlin bremen und
hamburg einen leicht rückläufigen trend
aufweisen so flächenstaaten wie bayern
hessen nordrhein westfalen baden
württemberg und niedersachsen sind fast
auf ganz stabilem niveau also da zeigt
sich wenig änderung wenn man alle
altersgruppen betrachtet und sachsen
anhalt und brandenburg deutschland die
tages incident sieben tage sind sie
dance leicht zugenommen
in thüringen deutlich und in sachsen
leider sehr deutlich wenn wir uns dann
die landkreise anschauen dann sehen wir
dass der überwiegende teil der großteil
der stadt und landkreisen nämlich 376
eine inzidenz von über 50 je 100000
einwohner in den letzten sieben tagen
haben und 273 haben über 124 auch über
250 je 100.000 einwohner
heute ist kein landkreis dabei der über
500.000 hatte aber alle großstädte die
mehr als 500.000 einwohnern sind haben
instanzen von 100 pro 100000 bevölkerung
in den letzten sieben tagen und die
einzige ausnahme dort ist hamburg wo wir
ebenfalls schon gesagt einen
rückläufigen trend sehen
wir schauen uns die bewertung für die
bewertung natürlich verschiedene
indikatoren an
und nicht nur die reinen fallzahlen und
instanzen und sie finden auch die zahlen
und abbildungen ja wie immer mit
einschätzung für jeden tag in unserem
situationsbericht auf der webseite der
ist am dienstag immer besonders
umfangreich wenn wir uns jetzt mal die
altersgruppen ansehen dann sehen wir
bitte grafik 2 die inzidenz nach
altersgruppen
diese abbildung habe ich ihn letzte
woche schon gezeigt haben wir auch in
unserem lagebericht und da sieht man
unten die meldewoche die 48 meldewoche
ist die letzte und man sieht als zeilen
aufgetragen die verschiedenen
altersgruppen und wir sind hier jetzt
ein bisschen feingliedriger vorgegangen
und haben das in fünf jahres schritten
gemacht so dass man jetzt die meisten
altersgruppen etwas feiner sehen kann
und je dunkler das kästchen desto höher
die altersgruppen spezifische inzidenz
eben in genau in dieser altersgruppe in
dieser meldung woche und da sehen sie
dass in den letzten wochen und vor allem
die jungen erwachsenen und erwachsenen
also die 15 bis 59 jährigen stark
betroffen waren am stärksten darunter
die 15 bis 29 jährigen und in diesen
altersgruppen lagen die sieben tages
inzidenz 'nen ja sogar bei über 200
400.000 es zeigt sich allerdings zuletzt
ein leichter rückgang wir beobachten
allerdings auch dass immer mehr ältere
menschen betroffen sind und wir sehen
dass die inzidenz der über 60-jährigen
insgesamt jetzt schon 119 400.000 in
sieben tagen beträgt
das war leider zu erwarten dass das
virus wenn es sich in den jüngeren
altersgruppen ausbreitet und dort
zirkuliert dann etwas zeitversetzt auch
in die älteren altersgruppen in die wohl
nach allen gruppen reinkommt und im
moment sind wirklich viele menschen über
80 jahre betroffen
die inzidenz in dieser altersgruppe
liegt auch insgesamt bei über 200
400.000 sie sehen in dieser abbildung je
älter desto höher am und sie das ist
auch besorgniserregend steigt wirklich
auch weiter an in den meisten anderen
altersgruppen stagniert die inzidenz
oder sie geht auch zurück aber eben
nicht bei den 11
von und hochaltrigen und dort sehen wir
eben auch jetzt immer mehr ausbrüche in
alten und pflegeheimen und dazu wird er
wieder ihnen gleich auch noch ein
bisschen mehr sagen ja das führt
natürlich weiterhin dazu dass sehr viele
menschen ins krankenhaus kommen und dass
auch die zahl der intensiv medizinisch
betreuten menschen zunimmt
die ist auch weiterhin hoch wenn auch
glücklicherweise nicht mehr so stark
ansteigend wie noch vor einiger zeit
also im oktober und im november als sie
jetzt ist es etwas weniger am anstieg es
befinden sich aber trotzdem fast 4000
menschen 3919 menschen mit stand gestern
soweit wie es um die wir intensiv
register wissen in intensivmedizinischer
behandlung
ja und diese entwicklung zeigt natürlich
auch und sorgt auch dafür dass immer
mehr menschen an und mit kuwait 19
sterben
wir schätzen dass etwa 800.000 menschen
die akute infektion überstanden haben
das ist natürlich sehr gut aber 17.600
zwei menschen sind auch daran gestorben
und die zahl der übermittelten
todesfälle steigt weiter an
für gestern wurden uns 479 neue
todesfälle übermittelt und für dienstag
waren es 487 das war unser bisheriger
trauriger höchststand wenn sie jetzt
bitte die grafik 3 einblenden könnten
genau diese grafik zeigt ihnen nach
sterbe woche wie viele menschen uns als
verstorben übermittelt werden
und wie gesagt die 48 kalenderwoche ist
die letzte woche und da sind auch noch
nachmeldungen möglich also zwischen dem
sterbe zeitpunkt und dem zeitpunkt dass
das in unserem meldesystem sichtbar wird
dass ein fall verstorben ist da können
noch ein paar tage vergehen
dadurch kann sich diese grafik auch noch
ändern
wir sehen dass ein großteil der menschen
die an coop 19 versterben älter als 70
jahre sind die meisten todesfälle sehen
wir in der altersgruppe der über
80-jährigen hier sind bislang schon elf
1572 todes
vermittelt worden aber auch in der
gruppe der 60 bis 69 jährigen sind
bislang mehr als 1500 menschen
verstorben
und auch in der altersgruppe der
zwischen 50 und 59 jährigen haben wir
über 500 todesfälle registriert
natürlich können auch jüngere menschen
schwere verläufe haben und auch an
spätfolgen leiden das ist aber zum glück
seltener ebenfalls in den älteren
altersgruppen
zusammenfassend kann man sagen dass das
virus in der jüngeren bevölkerung so
poliert und wenn es dort zirkuliert
daneben nach einer gewissen zeit auch in
die älteren in die hohen raten und
gruppen in die risikogruppen getragen
wird und das führt eben zu mehr schweren
verläufen und todesfällen und dadurch
ist es wirklich dafür ist es wirklich
wichtig dass sie ins ident sind ein
altersgruppen und auch in allen regionen
deutschlands zurück geht damit eben
weniger leute menschen mitbürger schwer
erkranken und auch versterben und über
die situation ein alten und pflegeheim
da wird man dann werden es in der zeit
im vergleich zum frühjahr weniger
menschen gibt die sich in krankenhäusern
am corona virus anstecken stecken sich
immer noch viele menschen in alten
pflegeheimen an
das bereitet uns tatsächlich große
sorgen denn gerade wie for excel
ausführte sind die älteren menschen
natürlich sehr gefährdet wenn sie bitte
die nächste grafik einblenden
nach unseren daten stecken sich ohne
bewohner häufiger an als das personal
und das zeigt ihnen diese grafik hier
die oben die betreuten infizierten
darstellt die obere linie und unten die
infizierten pflegekräfte generell
steigen die fallzahlen besonders in der
altersgruppe der menschen die 80 oder
älter sind und sie sehen sehr gut in der
oberen gruppe dass von den rund 33.000
infizierten die betreut sind doch
immerhin 5000 292 nach unseren
informationen verstorben sind und unten
sehen sie das bei den pflegekräften zum
einen natürlich deutlich weniger
pflegekräfte
infiziert werden sie sehen aber auch
dass dort der anteil der verstorbenen
geringer ist aber auch dort versterben
eben menschen
das ist sehr gefährlich alles da ältere
menschen besonders gefährdet sind an
kurven 19 zu versterben und wie diese
grafik zeigt wird fast jede fünfte
person die in alten pflegeheimen oder
gemeinschaftsunterkünften wohnen und
sich ansteckt daneben versterben
das sind die informationen die unseren
daten entnehmen können ich möchte ihnen
aber auch eine weitere grafik zeigen
um die situation nochmals zu
verdeutlichen das ist die nächste grafik
fünf bitte hier sieht man dass sich die
anzahl der ausbrüche in krankenhäusern
und altenpflegeheim auf einem ähnlich
hohen niveau befindet wie zu beginn der
pandemie sie sehen links die fallzahlen
in der achse und man sieht rote und
blaue bahn linien die roten linien sind
die erkrankungen in pflegeheimen und die
blauen linien sind die fälle und
ausbrüche in krankenhäusern und man kann
an der unteren grafik sehen dass die
anzahl der ausbrüche in den pflegeheimen
beziehungsweise krankenhäuser zunächst
relativ ähnlich verlief aber innerhalb
der letzten drei wochen sieht man dass
diese rote gestrichelte grafik dass
weniger ausbrüche in krankenhäusern
stattfinden das ist das eine was wir
sehen das andere was aber ebenfalls sehr
bedenklich ist dass die anzahl der
personen je ausbruch die in diesen
ausbrüchen also involviert sind in den
krankenhäusern zurückgeht während sie in
den pfleger im nach wie vor sehr hoch
ist
das heißt also die durchschnittliche
zahl von fällen pro ausbruch ist bei den
lose kommunalen ausbrüchen den in
krankenhaus geringer als im frühjahr und
wir vermuten dass dies auch auf eine
verbesserte ausbruchs prävention in
krankenhäusern und anderen einrichtungen
des gesundheitswesens zurückzuführen ist
hingegen ist die anzahl der fälle pro
aus wo in alten- und pflegeheim genauso
hoch wie das im frühjahr der fall war
diese meldedaten legen nahe dass die in
altenpfleger im eingeführten
präventionsmaßnahmen bisher nicht
vergleichbar erfolgreich
in ausbrüchen vorhin ausbrüche
verhindern unseren altenheim fehlen
gewisse möglichkeiten die krankenhäuser
haben
sie können zum beispiel nicht weniger
dringende eingriffe verschieben wir
müssen unsere ältesten mitmenschen daher
dringend schützen
der schutz wohl nabu-gruppen war von
anfang an ein ganz entscheidender
baustein unserer pandemie
bekämpfungsstrategie meine damen und
herren
wie gelingt es diese mitmenschen zu
schützen
das robert koch institut hat seit beginn
der pandemie umfassende empfehlungen
erstellt um den eintrag von lars koch 2
in alten- und pflegeheime zu verhindern
und beginnende ausbrüche rasch
einzudämmen
das robert-koch-institut hat sein
empfehlen dazu auch frau koch zum
aktualisiert sie finden das auf unserer
website wie immer unter www.rki.de /
kowitz strich 19
die altenpflegeheime benötigen aber auch
die notwendigen ressourcen um die
empfohlenen hygiene konzepte effektiv
umsetzen zu können
dafür sollten die träger sorgen die
heime müssen zudem in der schnellen
effektiven erkennung und eindämmung von
ausbrüchen mit hilfe der
gesundheitsämter unterstützt werden wir
sind jedoch meine damen und herren wir
sind jedoch alle in der verantwortung
das virus einzudämmen um unsere ältesten
mitmenschen zu schützen
liebe reicht es nicht dass wir uns zum
beispiel am arbeitsplatz mühe geben das
virus kennt keine grenzen und keine
uhrzeiten
wir müssen immer vor diesem virus auf
der hut sein auch im privaten umfeld
überall dort wo menschen zusammenkommen
und länger zusammenbleiben
dort steigt natürlich die chance einer
übertragung
das ist manchmal anstrengend oder
frustrierend und vielleicht fragen sie
sich manchmal wofür tun sie es für sich
selbst aber bitte tun sie es auch für
oma und opa und schauen sie mal bei
ich hatte corona rein
dort berichten betroffene jeden alters
von ihren erfahrungen mit cupid 19
diese krankheit wünschen wir keinem
und diese krankheit wollen wir auch
selber nicht haben und wir wünschen dir
schon gar nicht unseren ältesten
mitmenschen ein kurzes wort noch zur
quarantäne verkürzung die seit dem
ersten zwölften gilt quarantäne meine
damen und herren bedeutet dass personen
die möglicherweise kontakt mit dem virus
hatten beziehungsweise mit einem
infizierten person mit einer infizierten
person für einige zeit zu hause bleiben
und ihm möglichst damit sie möglichst
mit niemandem anderen kontakt haben der
sinn ist der dass sie eben das virus
nicht weiter tragen unsere
wissenschaftliche modellrechnungen haben
ergeben dass es möglichst die quarantäne
auf zehn tage zu verkürzen allerdings
nur dann wenn am tag zehn der quarantäne
der test ein test durchgeführt wird und
dieser test auch dann negativ ausfällt
in der nächsten grafik noch einmal
dargestellt die hatte ich ihnen bereits
schon mal gezeigt die grafik sechs die
sie auch auf unserer website finden dort
sehen sie noch mal die dauer der
isolierung also das sind patienten die
nachgewiesen positiv sind mit dem virus
und quarantäne sind die kontaktpersonen
die wir dann eben da die ware aus dem
verkehr ziehen quasi aus der infektions
verkehr so dass sie niemand anderen
anstecken können isolieren quarantäne
sind ganz wichtige säulen der bekämpfung
dieser pandemie
ich möchte noch mal das was frau doktor
rexroth und ich heute ihnen berichtet
zusammenfassen unser ziel ist nach wie
vor neuinfektionen so weit wie möglich
zu verhindern
und dieses ziel wird es auch während der
ganzen pandemie bleiben unser ziel ist
es die infektion wieder auf ein level zu
senken mit dem wir alle umgehen können
ich hoffe sehr dass wir das gemeinsam
schaffen und wir schaffen es auch nur
gemeinsam meine damen und herren ich
möchte auch noch einmal betonen dass für
saas kopf zwei nicht machtlos
gegenüberstehen
wir wissen wie wir das virus in schach
halten können und auch wenn der
impfstoff noch nicht da ist
denn wir haben eine gute gesamtstrategie
aber die beruht darauf dass sie alle
mitmachen
sie besteht aus drei elementen die wir
miteinander kombinieren der eindämmung
der krankheit dem schutz der besonders
gefährdeten gruppen und der abbildung
der folgen dieser pandemie eindämmung
bedeutet neue fälle verhindern
dazu können wir alle beitragen das
wissen sie das weiß ich wir sollten es
einfach tun schutz heißt besonders
gefährdete gruppen schützen
bildung bedeutet dass man die auswirkung
der panini abmildert zum beispiel
dadurch dass man die
behandlungskapazitäten ausweitet bzw
bessere therapien erarbeitet und das
meine damen und herren ist in den
letzten monaten auch geschehen aber
diese drei elemente müssen unbedingt
weiter aufrechterhalten bleiben die
ganze zeit bis diese pandemie beendet
ist noch einmal zum verständnis das
virus verbreitet sich überall dort wo
menschen zusammenkommen
das muss nicht immer eine große party
sein das risiko ist immer da besonders
wenn menschen ohne abstand und masken
zusammenkommen jede und jeder einzelne
von uns kann dazu beitragen infektionen
zu verhindern
darum lassen sie uns die aha + l regeln
in allen alltagssituationen beherzigen
und bitte lassen sie uns alle unsere
kontakte reduzieren und wenn die
symptome einer akuten atem in fraktion
auftreten
dann bleiben wir bitte alle
zusätzlich mindestens fünf tage zu hause
diese maßnahmen werden uns noch lange
begleiten solange bis ein relevanter
teil der bevölkerung durch eine impfung
geschützt ist und allen die diese
maßnahmen berücksichtigen möchte ich
noch einmal sagen sie schützen sich
selber und sie schützen aber auch andere
und sie tun es auch für oma und opa
ihnen ist es zu verdanken dass vielen
menschen schwere erkrankungen und leid
erspart geblieben sind und auch
zukünftig erspart bleiben
dafür möchte ich mich im namen von allen
sehr herzlich bei ihnen bedanken
vielen dank
dann können wir mit den fragen starten
wir beginnen mit n-tv herr als er wieder
für ihre ausführungen inzidenz der
älteren das haben wir auch eine reaktion
die veröffentlichung wird immer steigt
nach wie vor täglich an
können sie sagen wie viel prozent der
neuinfektionen eigentlichen pflege haben
und in bei den einrichtungen insgesamt
ungefähr prozentual zu verorten sind und
sie sagten schon schuttmassen anja die
würden sie beurteilen die schnelltests
ein baustein um die wohlhabenden gruppen
in den pflege- und altenheim besser zu
schätzen
ja wir haben ja zahlen in unserem
situationsbericht in denen sie sehen wie
viele menschen gemeldet werden das heißt
also diese zahlen bei aller
untererfassung die natürlich immer
dieses meldesystem hat sehen wir dass
doch einige in diesen ein heim in den
entsprechenden pflegeheim angesteckt
werden aber selbstverständlich geschieht
dies eben auch außerhalb von pflegeheim
und das ist ja der appell wir müssen
verstehen dass es überall geschehen kann
und dort wo wir unter besonders gut
kontrollierten bedingungen arbeiten
dort sollte es eben seltener geschehen
das heißt also in den pflege- und
altenheim sollte natürlich die konzepte
die wir ja erarbeitet haben sollten dort
besonders intensiv umgesetzt werden die
konzepte sehen hygiene vor das ist klar
und die konzepte sehen natürlich auch
zugangsregelungen vor
die konzepte sähen vor dass alle die in
diesen einrichtungen arbeiten mund nasen
schutz
die konzepte sehen auch vor dass die
nicht wenn fälle wirklich etabliert sind
dass man bestimmte kotierung und
durchführt dass man gruppen trend wenn
dies möglich ist noch nicht infizierten
vielleicht infizierten infizierten und
dabei spielt natürlich auch die testung
eine rolle
die tests strategien die werden ja von
den altenheimen und pflegeheim
erarbeitet und werden dann gemeinsam mit
den gesundheitsämtern abgestimmt und
diese test strategien sind wichtig aber
ich möchte auf eine einen aspekt
hinweisen der von dem ich das gefühl
habe dass er immer wieder falsch
verstanden wird
die testungen dienen ja in erster linie
dazu zu überprüfen ob ein test konnten
schon ein hygiene konzept auch wirklich
funktioniert es ist ja quasi ein
indikator dafür dass das konzept
funktioniert und natürlich dient es auch
dazu dass man einen eventuellen fall
früher ermittelt aber die hauptsächliche
grund warum wir diese testung dort haben
ist um zu überprüfen ob das hygiene
konzept funktioniert denn der test
selber auch wenn er negativ ausfällt
bedeutet ja kein schutz vor der
krankheit also in dieser falschen
sicherheit dürfen wir uns nie wiegen das
ist wichtig dass man nicht denkt nur
wenn man einen negativen test hat dass
man deshalb geschützt oder krankheit
denn der test kann er einen tag später
positiv ausfallen also das heißt
sinnvoll eingesetzt sind tests ein ganz
ganz wichtiger baustein der strategie
und wir sind das ja auch sehr froh dass
es jetzt diese anti gen tests gibt dir
auch hier eine ganz ganz wichtige rolle
haben aber gibt es da noch andere
branche nachfrage desinfektions der
selber das infektionsgeschehen ist nach
wie vor sehr hoch dort und stand gehen
noch weiter an gibt es denn noch
irgendwelche dinge die man jetzt
zusätzlich machen kann um das den
weiteren anstieg zu verhindern also
unser eindruck ist dass man das was man
machen kann tun sollte ja wir müssen
nicht ständig neue ideen entwickeln
sondern wir müssen das was wir wissen
konsequent umsetzen
darauf lege ich sehr sehr viel wert wie
haben wir auch immer mehr neue
technische möglichkeiten aber fakt ist
dass das verhalten der menschen im
vordergrund steht und wir sehen sicher
nicht überall dass die maßnahmen
konsequent umgesetzt werden das ist der
beste schutz die konsequente umsetzung
und das bedeutet eben das entsprechende
verhalten und die fronten
verantwortungsbewusstsein aller der
beteiligten die umsetzung von den
maßnahmen die compliance das ist aus
meiner sicht der wichtigste punkt
wir gehen zu dpa frau groos von morgen
morgen alles klar er will ich wüsste
gerne von ihnen die kanzlerin hat ja
gestern abend noch mal bekräftigt das
incident von unter 50 erreicht werden
soll ist es denn ein ziel was wir in
deutschland aus ihrer sicht mit denen
jetzt verabredeten maßnahmen auch für
weihnachten erreichen können und wenn ja
wie lange das voraussichtlich dauern und
dann noch eine kleine nachfragen sie den
schnelltest sekunden der kollege hat das
ja gerade auch schon angesprochen
jetzt hat er sparen ja eine ausweitung
auch für lehrer und erzieher ins
gespräch gebracht die das nach einer
schulung selbst machen können sollen
wie sinnvoll halten sie das und ist es
dann auch den schritt dahin dass es
früher oder später auch viele
privatpersonen selbst machen kann
danke ja vergoss also die erste frage
die die erste folge vergessen
vielleicht kann nicht das ziel der
50.000 inwieweit das realistisch ist bis
weihnachten also sie haben ja auch gute
beispiele
wir sehen zum beispiel hamburg in
hamburg hat 69 je 100000 jetzt und die
waren zwischenzeitlich spitzenreiter
also es geht
die fallzahlen zu senken es geht nicht
wahnsinnig schnell also wir brauchen
ziemlich viel geduld und beharrlichkeit
aber ist es geht ob das jetzt wirklich
will
innerhalb dieser zeit an allen orten
oder auch im insgesamten
bundesdurchschnitt möglich ist das hängt
wieder gesagt hat wirklich von der
compliance ab und wir brauchen auch ein
bisschen geduld um zu sehen ob die
maßnahmen wirken oder dass sie wirken
und es muss eben wirklich wie gesagt in
allen altersgruppen und in allen
regionen auch umgesetzt werden aber in
einen einzelnen stellen geht das auf
jeden fall ja
also das ist der entscheidende punkt das
hängt maßgeblich von der compliance aber
das hängt maßgeblich vom verhalten der
menschen ab wie schnell das machbar ist
es ist prinzipiell machbar
zu ihrer zweiten frage mit den tests die
tests sind wichtige strategische mittel
aber sie müssen eben auch sinnvoll und
wichtig eingesetzt werden und da gibt es
ja entsprechende empfehlung gerade für
die schulen will dir das an sprachen
gibt es ja ebenfalls empfehlungen und in
den schulen
da ist es natürlich ganz klar dass wir
auch infektionsgeschehen dort haben und
wir sehen dass in den schulen
das infektionsgeschehen die dynamik der
bevölkerung quasi hinterherläuft wir
hatten ja nach den sommerferien die
schulen wieder geöffnet und wir haben
erst dann deutlich später auch mehr
fälle in den schulen gesehen und ein
anstieg in der inzidenz in diesen
jüngeren altersgruppen die entwicklung
dieser inzidenz scheint parallel zur
entwicklung der inzidenz der jungen
erwachsenen zu verlaufen
und diese ausbrüche wir nehmen ja auch
immer mehr ausbrüche im schulzeit in war
wir haben insgesamt bis gestern 636
ausbrüche in schulen übermittelt
bekommen
in den letzten vier wochen waren das 64
ausbrüche pro woche das heißt also auch
in den schulen macht es natürlich sinn
im rahmen aber wie gesagt nur im rahmen
eines gesamten hygiene konzeptes und da
gibt es ja klare empfehlungen vom robert
koch institut im rahmen eines klaren
hygiene konzeptes sind diese testungen
sinnvoll und es wäre am besten wenn es
doch einen bestimmten lehrer zum
hygienebeauftragten ernannt würde dieser
natürlich auch entsprechend
weitergebildet wird von den lokalen
behörden um dann diese tests sinnvoll
einzusetzen
dazu bedarf es einer gewissen kenntnis
aber das ist
das ist wirklich machbar aber ich sage
es nochmal die tests haben wirklich nur
dann ein wirklich hohen erfolgsaussicht
wenn sie in eine gesamtstrategie und
zwar die umsetzung der empfehlung des
robert koch- institut für schulen
eingebettet sind
vielen dank beginn zu rtl
hallo tamara bilic von rtl auch noch mal
eine frage zu den schnelltest von den
schulen jetzt mal vielleicht zum thema
veranstaltungen wäre wären die
schnelltests zb auch eine neue strategie
um veranstaltung zeitnah wieder zu
ermöglichen
also die schnelltests dielen dazu dass
sie in dem moment wo sie testen mit
einer gewissen wahrscheinlichkeit
menschen identifizieren die positiv sind
oder negativ sind
wenn personen positiv getestet werden
dann müssen sie sich isolieren
aber ich möchte noch mal folgendes sagen
diese schnelltests sind momentaufnahmen
und alle zusammenkünfte und je mehr
menschen zusammen kommen alle
zusammenkünfte behalten trotzdem ein
risiko weil diese schnelltests natürlich
nicht 100 prozent sicher sind also sie
können das ergebnis nicht für 100% bare
münze nehmen und darum halte ich nach
wie vor die maßnahme dass man
zusammenkünfte von vielen menschen
einfach unterbindet für die effektivste
maßnahme denn dort können infektionen zu
stande kommen ja und so lange wir ein
bestimmtes niveau nicht unterbrochen
haben also zu lange wir diese 50 100.000
nicht erreicht haben sind zusammenkünfte
von menschen einfach ein risiko das wir
aus infektionsschutz gründen nicht
eingehen sollten
ich habe starke zu den zentren mehrere
wissenschaftliche fachgesellschaften
haben ja kritisiert dass die daten der
jüngsten dort nicht an die krankenkassen
übermittelt werden dh sowie das modell
jetzt konstruiert ist gibt es keine
möglichkeit zum beispiel seltene und
schwere nehmen
in den routinedaten zur zu entdecken
finden sie das richtig
daten zu erheben indem zum beispiel die
versicherten ihre versichertenkarte bei
dem indischen einlesen also der
entscheidende es gibt zwei gründe oder
mehrere aber ich sage ihnen die zwei
wichtigsten gründe aus meiner
wahrnehmung warum wir impfzentren
benötigen
der eine punkt ist der es ist natürlich
logistisch und da muss jeder einfach mal
in ruhe drüber nachdenken das ist
logistisch natürlich eine riesige
aufgabe wenn wir 10 20 30 millionen
menschen impfen wollen kontrolliert
impfen wollen nach einem bestimmten
bestellsystem impfen wollen
das kann man nur in zentren schaffen das
ist momentan gar nicht anders möglich
wenn wir einen bestimmten prozentsatz
der bevölkerung geimpft haben dann wird
das sicher auch in arztpraxen möglich
sein
der zweite punkt warum wir aber gerade
impfzentren brauchen ist genau der dänen
sie nennen wir wollen nämlich die
nebenwirkungen so gut wie möglich
monitoren und dafür sind die daten die
wir über die krankenkassen bekommen
deutlich zu langsam
wir brauchen die daten sofort das heißt
also es werden dort entsprechende
systeme etabliert auch das
robert-koch-institut selber ist
involviert in die etablierung einer
bestimmten software wo diese dinge genau
monitor werden nach untersucht werden
und dann eben direkt zentral erfasst
werden können das ist ein ganz wichtiger
aspekt dass wir dafür beschreiben nicht
nur die schutzwirkung dieser impfung
sondern die nebenwirkung und wir dürfen
uns auch über eines müssen wir uns auch
klar sein
in deutschland sterben jahr im schnitt
zur und 2005 2700 menschen jeden tag das
ist die normale todesrad in deutschland
sterben im jahr so circa 900.000
menschen und das heißt also es wird
unter allem ihr auch vorkommen dass ist
einfach mit einer statistischen
wahrscheinlichkeit verbunden dass auch
menschen zeitlichen zusammenhang mit der
impfung versterben werden und dann ist
natürlich extrem wichtig herauszufinden
ob der grund die impfung war oder eben
eine andere zugrundeliegende krankheit
denn wir werden ja auch am anfang gerade
die hoch risikogruppen impfen und das
sind ja gerade auch die
alten und hochaltrigen menschen die
natürlich ebenfalls ein höheres risiko
haben zu versterben ganz einfach weil
sie schon ein hohes alter erreicht haben
und genau deshalb brauchen wir im
zentrum und eine zentrale erfassung von
den nebenwirkungen ich meine nachfrage
dazu mir leuchtet es ehrlich gesagt
nicht ganz ein wenn die menschen die eng
ziehen anschließend beschweren haben
dann gehen sie damit zu ihrem arzt ihrem
haus aus diese daten werden dann
sozusagen ja an die krankenkassen
übermitteln wie wird das kombinierte
jetzt die lagen diese daten kombiniert
mit dem central der erhobenen daten in
den impfzentren dafür eine software ein
portal das wir zur verfügung stellen und
es gibt auch noch dazu noch weitere
daten die von seiten des
paul-ehrlich-instituts erhoben werden
also wir haben systeme im wir bauen
systeme auf die garantieren dass wir
diese informationen
guten tag herr professor wiler guten tag
frau dr rexroth stichwort protection
nochmal in der strategie sie haben ja
eindrücklich gezeigt dass das
sterberisiko von älteren menschen
besonders hoch ist dass das auch die
ursache für viele intensiv behandlungen
ist inwieweit tragen denn aus ihrer
sicht die maßnahmen des teil locker und
so wie sie jetzt verhängten sind
überhaupt zur protection bei jenseits
dessen das natürlich kontakte vermieden
werden und ähnliche dinge dann reduziert
werden aber fehlt es nicht eigentlich an
der gewichtung die protection auch
politisch in den vordergrund zu rücken
also ich glaub die zahlen von frau
wächst das können wir noch noch ergänzen
und die zahlen von forex rot zeigen ja
genau das ein ganz wichtiger teil der
protection derjenige ist das eben die
jüngeren altersgruppen sich weniger
infizieren will sie das natürlich auch
zu den eltern dann tragen wir sehen ja
bei den incidents zahlen dass die
hochaltrigen eine sehr hohe inzidenz
haben wir sehen aber die unter 80 60 bis
da sehen wir niedrigere instanzen und
das interpretieren wir so dass diese
menschen sich natürlich auch selber noch
mehr schützen können ihr verhalten
entsprechend anpassen können gerade die
die eigenständig ihr leben noch waren da
sehen wir von den menschen dass sie sich
wirklich sehr sehr sehr stark
zusammenreißen wir haben ganz so
compliance in dieser altersgruppe
darum denke ich dass die maßnahmen der
gesamten kontakt reduktion das nach wie
vor wichtigste sind aber ich möchte das
noch mal sagen die protection über die
wir jetzt brauchen gerade im altersheim
pflegeheim
das sind ja menschen die sind die leben
dort und die sind schutzbedürftig die
können von den einrichtungen oder müssen
von den einrichtungen geschützt werden
so gut es geht die können also direkt
geschützt wenn das sind aber in
deutschland meines wissens 8 bis 900.000
menschen wären wir viel mehr die zu
dieser altersgruppe gehören zu der
risiko altersgruppe und die können wir
wirklich nur schützen durch das
verhalten das wir dafür sorge tragen
dass wir keine infektion weiter tragen
und darum ist die gesamte reduktion der
kontakte
das ist wirklich der schlüssel zum
erfolg aber wir brauchen die komplett
wir brauchen die compliance dass alle
menschen das auch machen und was immer
für regeln wie auch aufstellen werden
wenn die compliance nicht stimmt dann
wird es schwierig ich habe noch eine
nachfrage zur kontakt nachverfolgung das
betrifft ja auch die 50er inzidenz auf
die doch die meisten politischen
maßnahmen jetzt fokussiert sind das
system sommers soll ja flächendeckend
bis ende des jahres bei allen
gesundheitsämtern eingesetzt werden
das wären wenn ich richtig informiert
bin noch 300 gesundheitsämter die das
bis jahresende einführen müssten
wie sieht es da aus sind sie da
optimistisch dass das gelingen kann
also ich kann den ich bezahl nicht
genommen ob das bis jahresende gelingt
das vermag ich nicht zu sagen ich weiß
nur dass sehr viele anstrengungen
durchgeführt werden dass es eingeführt
wird und insofern wird es auch
eingeführt
das ist ja ein system was aber
ausschließlich die kontakt
nachverfolgung im mittelpunkt hat das
heißt also dass das erleichtert wenn es
implementiert ist den gesundheitsämtern
sicher die kontakt nachverfolgung und
erhöht damit auch die chancen dass man
eben kontakte schneller findet
ich gehe doch ich kann ihnen nicht genau
sagen das datum aber das wird zügig mit
mit mit hochdruck der aktuell in einer
an händler an annähernd 400
gesundheitsämter eingeführt ich möchte
dazu noch eins sagen leider gottes ist
es in deutschland so dass es eben keine
einheitliche melde software gibt wir
stellen vom robert koch institut die
software servlet kostenfrei den
gesundheitsämtern zur verfügung und da
ist ja auch ein wesentlicher punkt dass
eben die schnittstellen zu sommers hier
da hergestellt werden und die kann man
natürlich direkt anbinden
aber es gibt eben leider in deutschland
verschiedene software und deshalb muss
dieses sommers an verschiedene software
verknüpft werden und unten
schnittstellen gebaut werden und das
verlangsamt natürlich den prozess das
ist aber so in deutschland ich glaube
wir haben inzwischen wie viel sind an
servlet haben inzwischen 250 oder irgend
sowas also für mehr als die hälfte am
server aber das ist weniger versäumnis
als das ist das ist der föderalismus der
eben in den letzten jahren einfach dazu
geführt hat dass nicht eine einheitliche
software benutzt wird
ja danke meine frage an herrn wieder
oder forex trotz andere länder die teils
viel höhere infektionen hatten haben
inzwischen stark rückläufige zahlen also
in europa in deutschland ist die kurve
tat gefragt aber die fälle stagnieren ja
hat deutschland ist verpasst eine
schnellere reduktion der zahlen zu
schaffen welche maßnahmen sehen sie
woanders die womöglich besonders
effektiv waren und herr wieder kurz zur
impfung noch sehen sie da eine
möglichkeit die krone war irgendwie in
den prozess einzubinden also die erste
frage wir gucken immer in zeiträumen
das habe ich von anfang an immer gesagt
auch als deutschland so großartig
darstellen und als beispiel für viele
genommen wurde
war uns immer klar wir schauen immer in
einer zeitfenster und momentan kriegen
wir die zahlen eben nicht mit aller
verve unter anderen länder haben das
geschafft sie haben recht belgien zum
beispiel oder frankreich und die gründe
dafür liegen einfach letztlich darin wie
die menschen sich verhalten wie die
compliance der leute ist und ich habe
bei uns jetzt tatsächlich die hoffnung
wir haben waren im frühjahr sehr
erfolgreich und im frühjahr ist etwas
geschehen was leider als sogenanntes
präventions- paradox dargestellt werden
muss es gab viele leute die eben
überhaupt keinen kontakt hatten zu kurve
kranken
es gibt nach wie vor menschen die die
leute ihnen diese krankheit und ich bin
sehr sicher dass inzwischen mehr von
diesen fällen auftreten auch im
bekanntenkreis doch inzwischen immer
mehr menschen merken dass diese
krankheit wirklich eine ernst zu
nehmende ist die sie nicht haben möchten
die auch teilweise bei milden verläufen
langwierige langzeitfolgen hat die die
ja auch immer offensichtlicher werden so
dass ich denke dass die compliance
steigt der zweite punkt der impfung die
korona vanek ist ein tool das der sind
der korona vanek war der dass man
möglichst sich wenn man sich nicht
erinnern kann wo man angesteckt wurde
dass man gewarnt wird dass man gewarnt
wird und dann schneller dadurch dass man
gewalt wird schneller selber ein test
macht und dann schneller sich in
quarantäne begibt und und
beziehungsweise isolierung wenn man
positiv war und wir überlegen
verschiedene dinge mit der krone war
nett aber es ist es ich kann ihn nicht
genau sagen was am ende dort alles
rauskommt momentan sehe ich im bereich
der impfung die korona vanek nicht als
ein tool was wir einsetzen könnten das
mag sich aber ändern wenn ich danach
haben kann also dass die einladungen
angeht oder die nachverfolgung von
symptomen sehen sie dieses moderne mit
dass inzwischen mehr als 20 millionen
downloads hat nicht als nützlich sondern
weiterhin briefe und die üblichen wege
also es wird ja darüber nachgedacht ob
man zum beispiel ein symptom tagebuch
in der korona vanek einbringt und der
grund ist der dass man damit insgesamt
die schärfe der warnungen also die
genauigkeit der warnungen erhöht es gibt
verschiedene modelle auf wie gesagt im
moment im zusammenhang mit der impfung
sehe ich das nicht aber das mag sich
auch ändern ja die zeile so kurzlebig
und sie wissen ja es gibt immer wieder
auch neue entwicklungen es gibt ja eine
reihe von software ist die entwickelt
werden auch von anderen
und wer weiß was dort alles noch an
möglichkeiten auf uns zukommt wir gehen
zum deutschlandfunk wildermuth ich
wollte ja noch mal zurück zu den
schnelltest dass die zeit haben stabile
ich wollte dir fragen gibt es studien
die zeigen dass leute die angeleitet
werden tatsächlich genauso verlässlich
und stellte ist abnehmen können wie
medizinisches personal von zweitens wenn
an den schulen getestet wird muss das
dann auch die positiven tests an das
gesundheitsamt gemeldet werden dass
studien gibt ja schon hätte es wird in
studien auch eingesetzt auch sogar also
der selbst auch der selbst die selbst
abnahme aber wir empfehlen das bis jetzt
noch nicht in der selbst abnahme den
schnelltest da wird es sicherlich
entwicklungen geben über kurz oder lang
wo das auch für die für eine breitere
anwendung möglich ist bis jetzt ist da
schon noch ein gewisser medizinischer
sachverstand und schulung notwendig also
das was jetzt den schnee das betrifft
und die zweite frage war vergessen
die zweite frage war ob wenn an den
schulen breit schnelltest eingeführt
werden da gibt es positive befunde
meldepflicht auf jeden fall also das ist
allerdings also die positiven nachweise
antigenen und pcs sind meldepflichtig
jeder direkte indirekte nachweis ist
meldepflichtig allerdings nicht in dem
sinne für jeden also es gibt
unterschiedliche meldepflichtige und da
sind natürlich ärzte labore aber auch
leiter von einrichtungen dabei von
meiner seite noch der hinweis in hessen
gibt es eine studie professor tätig
er hat mit lehrern studie durchgeführt
ich weiß aber nicht ob die schon
ausgewertet ist nicht wir gehen zu dts
nachrichtenagentur herr hoffmann ja
geborgen
der herr professor trotzdem hat kürzlich
gesagt dass mehr groß sei jetzt der
nächste pandemie kandidat sehen sie das
auch so
ich weiß nicht aber das gesagt hat ich
weiß nur dass wir natürlich dass wir
davon ausgehen müssen dass immer mal
wieder pandemien auftreten
deshalb haben wir ja auch pandemiepläne
in unserem land nur wir hatten wie die
meiste teil der welt sich halt
vorwiegend auf influenza vorbereitet
aber diese pläne sind natürlich in einem
hohen maße flexibel und dem geschehen
jetzt angepasst das ist ja auch ein
virus das über die atemwege übertragen
wird ich vermag nicht zu sagen was das
nächste pandemische virus sein wird ich
möchte zunächst mal dieses bekämpfen und
zwar mit aller macht und mit einer
unterstützung die wir eine bevölkerung
haben und was mir auch wichtig ist
vielleicht an dieser stelle noch zu
sagen was sicher kommt und da brauchen
wir nicht zu spekulieren das ist die
grippe ja und die kommt nämlich jedes
jahr und wir wissen aber nicht wie stark
die grippe sein wird in diesem jahr und
wir wissen auch nicht welche viren es
gibt ja immer verschiedene grippeviren
die wir durch diesen impfstoff abdecken
wie viele es sein wenn wir wissen nicht
die krankheitslast aber weil sie eben
auch hier noch mal klar sagen möchte
jetzt heute und die nächsten wochen
monate schützen wir uns mit den
maßnahmen die wir aufgrund von kogit
fahren also abstand halten
hygieneregeln schützen wir uns natürlich
auch vor grippe und das ist jetzt
erstmal vorne dass wir möglichst eine
flache grippewelle haben insofern wäre
ich umso glücklicher wenn diese
maßnahmen auch konsequent durchgeführt
werden unter anderem auch in den schulen
warum in den schulen ist es dann gerade
wichtig bei influenza grippe wissen wir
dass die schulen ein ganz ganz wichtiger
teil des geschehens sind also da sind
die schulen die jungen kinder wirklich
immer richtig ein etwas was wir als
treiber bezeichnen das heißt also wenn
wir in den schulen die hygiene konzepte
fahren die jetzt von uns empfohlen
werden dann werden wir damit auch das
krippe geschehen reduzieren das ist
zunächst mal deutlich wichtiger weil wir
aktuell und ganz sicher diese
grippewelle haben werden wir wissen nur
noch nicht genau wie stark sie
wir gehen zu frau rosbach sagen sie
nochmal ihre redaktion dazu die deutsche
zeitung
ich habe eine frage zum thema impfen
beziehungsweise der reihenfolge in der
geben soll
gestern hatte die bundeskanzlerin noch
mal deutlich gemacht dass die
feinabstimmung durch die ständige
impfkommission und das dem
gesundheitsministerium als empfehlung
gegeben werden sollte das aber man da
abhängig sei von dem zulassungsverfahren
also dass da quasi alle unterlagen die
in dem zulassungsverfahren eine rolle
spielen eben auch vorliegen und bekannte
mich interessiert mal aus persönlicher
sicht warum ist das eigentlich so ich
meine wir wissen doch schon bereitet
viele bei den fünf top sowie das
großbritannien schon zugelassen hat
warum müssen wir jetzt für die
feinabstimmung werde wirklich zuerst
gehen wird und in welcher reihenfolge
darauf warten dass dieses thema
verfahren zur anfrage
naja ich kann ihnen das sagen warum das
so ist
es gibt ja diese drei klinischen phasen
die dritte ist ja diejenigen die uns
natürlich am meisten interessiert die
kommt er erst nur zustande wenn die
ersten beiden erfolgreichen
durchgelaufen sind und diese einzelnen
daten da sind meines wissens über
400.000 menschen geimpft worden entweder
mit dem warum also mit dem impfstoff
oder mit einem placebo
das sind die wichtigen daten die zeigen
uns ja genau wie die schutz
funktionen sind und sie zeigen uns vor
allem auch wie die nebenwirkungen sind
das sind extrem wichtige daten und wir
tun gut daran wenn wir die in ruhe
studieren
ob ich dann noch änderungen in die
unseren einschätzungen ergeben das
vermag ich nicht zu sagen wir bekommen
die daten jetzt dieser tage erst aber
auf diesen daten beruht ja die ganze zu
lassen also ich will sie wie wir wissen
ja dass die ganze zulassung relativ
rasch erfolgt und ich glaube zwei drei
tage länger noch zu warten um diese zu
lassen um diese daten richtig zu
analysieren
das sollten wir uns schon alle geben und
auch der ema geben denn sie müssen immer
auch klar davon ausgehen dass wir
natürlich immer wieder auch viel kritik
haben werden wir werden wir haben
menschen in unserer gesellschaft die ja
sogar richtig aktive impfgegner sind und
wir werden natürlich auch nebenwirkungen
haben und wir werden sicher nichts tun
dass uns im nachhinein vorgeworfen
werden könnte wir hätten nachlässig mit
informationen werden wir umgegangen
nein wir müssen seriös so gut wie
möglich nach bestem wissen und gewissen
die daten die wir haben auswirken ja
also hatte für die impfung sind ja die
bundesländer zuständig und die bauern
hat diese zentren auf die bauern die
zentren auf und ich bin da sehr
optimistisch dass das dann auch zeitnah
erfolgt und wenn es mal ein tag oder
zwei tage länger dauert das ist ein
logistischer aufwand da sollte man auch
immer mit gesundem menschenverstand
rangehen aber es wird alles in einem
ziemlich großen tempo gemacht mit
sicherheit wird es hier und dort auch
mal kleine fehler geben oder
versäumnisse aber prinzipiell bin ich
sehr sehr voll überzeugt dass wir die
struktur auf die beine bekommen
und der wird eine zulassung um ein zwei
tage früher oder später dort keinen
unterschied machen
wir gehen zur frau dillmann handelsblatt
oder zumindest lange nicht so sicher
sind wie ein pc ist wissen wir wie
sicher sie sind und wissen wir dass für
die einzelnen tests und die andere frage
ist die whu empfiehlt neuerdings masken
tragen auch zu hause wenn ich gesucht
habe auch wenn ich abstand halten was
sagen sie dazu
also war ein bisschen unglücklich
ausgedrückt es gibt natürlich keinen
100% sicheren test den den gibt es
prinzipiell nicht aber wir haben tests
die eben eine sehr sehr hohe sicherheit
genauigkeit spezifität und sensitivität
haben wir sind die pcr tests das ist der
so genannte goldstandard der über viele
jahre in vielen anderen bereichen
wirklich sehr sehr gut verifiziert wurde
akkreditierte methoden sind wir machen
ja viele diagnostik mit pizza in der
infektionsmedizin und anderswo die
schnelltests werden geprüft sie werden
validiert darin ist das
robert-koch-institut auch daran ist dass
roter thun involviert in diese tests und
es gibt eine liste beim b fahren also
beim bundesinstitut für arzneimittel und
medizinprodukte
dort stehen die test drauf und die tests
die dann bei der validierung durch
fallen die werden dort gestrichen was
wir momentan sehen ist dass die tests
vor allen dingen halt gut geeignet sind
dafür infektiöse patienten zu erkennen
sie müssen nicht vorstellen es gibt
immer eine phase also wo man infiziert
ist als patient in der zeit hat man noch
keine symptome
und es ist eine zeit wo man dann sehr
viel virus ausschaltet und am ende ist
man immer noch infiziert aber mann
scheidet nicht mehr aus es gibt
eigentlich drei phasen phase ist
infiziert ohne ausscheidungsphase b ist
infiziert mit ausscheidung da kann man
also andere menschen infizieren und
phase c ist man ist immer noch infiziert
aber schaltet auch nicht mehr aus und
diese phase b das heißt die phase wo das
virus in einer menge ausgeschieden wird
dass wir denken dass der andere
angesteckt wenn die kann man mit diesen
anti gen test ganz gut erkennen
entschuldigung wenn ich danach fragen
gab die sagen die durchfallen
durchgestrichen aber was heißt es gibt
berichte von einzelnen schnelltest wo
sich dann irgendwie 20 leute im
pflegeheim negativ getestet wurde und
dann hat man einen pcr-test hinterher
geschoben und dann war die hälfte halt
doch positiv also kann man das irgendwie
in prozent angeben kann ich nicht tun
das tut mir leid weil es eben so viele
tests gibt wir prüfen die natürlich
immer nach bestem wissen und gewissen
durch und natürlich haben auch die
hersteller eine pflicht so genannte post
marketing studien zu machen um die
qualität der tests weiter zu prüfen
auf diese liste zu kommen
gute frage die ich ihnen nicht
beantworten kann man da muss ich noch
mal nachfragen es gibt kriterien
ich habe es aber nicht im kopf und
morgen herr fieber herr müller sie haben
gesagt dass die lage weiterhin
angespannt bleibt
wenn wir uns die zahl der neuinfektionen
und auch der todesfälle ansieht dann ist
das ja tatsächlich so aber gibt es etwas
nur einen trend der ihn trotz alledem
hoffnung macht ja das hat heute gut
dargestellt
sie hat ja gezeigt und wenn sie in
unseren situationsbericht gucken dann
glaube ich sehen sie denn auch ganz gut
sie sehen ja dass in allen altersgruppen
mit ausnahme der hochaltrigen die
instanzen sinken also wer den leichte
erholung leichter erholung eben sehr
langsam und und auch zu langsam aber wir
sehen diese erholung wie sehen diese
zahlen und das ist ein trend der in die
richtige richtung geht und ich kann es
nur noch mal sagen ich wäre einfach
glücklich wirklich alle von uns diese
krankheit so ernst nehmen und wahrnehmen
dass sie versuchen dich so gut wie
möglich an diese regeln zu halten wissen
sie ich weiß dass das ja auch gar nicht
jedem gelingen kann es gibt ja
verschiedene lebens zu stellen es gibt
bestehende wohn umstände wir wissen dass
es eine bestimmte gruppe gibt von
menschen sind natürlich wie immer die
armen die prekär erleben denn die haben
eine größeres problem diese regeln
sollen aber die eine großteil der
wirkung kann diese regeln einhalten und
ich kann immer nur wieder an diese
menschen appellieren dass wir das alle
tun denn damit bringen wir natürlich
auch den reduzierung auf den druck auf
die anderen also ist liegt wirklich an
unserem verhalten
diese pandemie lebt nur von unserem
verhalten dieses virus springt nur über
wenn wir ihm die chance geben das heißt
also ich kann immer nur an uns alle
appellieren dass wir das ernst nehmen
und damit wir die zahlen runter kriegen
und das ist der optimismus den ich habe
ich weiß dass die mehrheit der
bundesdeutschen das ja auch versteht und
tut aber ich weiß das ist ja sogar
menschen gibt die selbst die krankheit
leugnen und das ist bitter bedauerlich
weil die riskieren nicht nur ihre eigene
gesundheit sondern eben auch leider die
gesundheit ihrer mitmenschen
wir gehen zu andreas rinke sagen sie
noch ihre redaktionen dazu bitte ja
hallo andreas rinke von reuters das
eindrucksvoll beschrieben gerade am
anfang dass vor allem die älteren sich
anstecken muss man nicht fürchten dass
die weihnachts von regelungen also
lockerungen kann den kontakt
beschränkung dann einen richtigen schub
an neuinfektionen gerade in dieser
gruppe bringen also ist das nicht
kontraproduktiv und eine kurze nachfrage
an frauen rexroth dass das regionale
gefälle angeht können sie dafür auch
noch eine erklärung liefern also warum
scheint der norden im moment besser die
lage in den griff zu bekommen als den
süden und der osten
danke also wir sollten alle auch über
die weihnachtsfeiertage wirklich
versuchen unsere kontakte so stark wie
möglich einzuschränken das ist gar keine
frage
und man sollte die feiern glichkeiten
eben so gestalten dass man dann
zeitversetzt bestimmte mitmenschen und
familienmitglieder trifft das ist gar
keine frage
also wir sollten uns versuchen die
kontakte nach wie vor so gut wie möglich
zu reduzieren
ja zu dem gefälle dem regionalen gefälle
also was ganz genau in den einzelnen
bundesländern vor sich geht und auch
landkreisen da müssten sie wirklich
entsprechend bei den bundesländern und
land
nachfragen aber man sieht natürlich in
deutschland dass es regionale
unterschiede gibt wir hatten zunächst
sehr starken nord-süd-gefälle und vor
allem in bayern baden-württemberg
saarland war in sozial sehr stark
betroffen und schleswig-holstein
mecklenburg-vorpommern sind überhaupt
bislang relativ gut vor allem
mecklenburg vorpommern durch diese lage
gekommen die aus bundesländer waren
bislang nicht so betroffen und sind
jetzt eben auch vor allem die südlichen
sachsen sachsen-anhalt und thüringen
eben auch stärker deutlich stärker
betroffen als vorher was die
gesamtanzahl betrifft der fälle haben
die noch nicht das niveau jetzt erreicht
was in bayern baden-württemberg gesehen
wurde über die gesamte pandemie
das ist natürlich schon
besorgniserregend dass es in manchen
gebieten deutschlands jetzt ungebrochen
weiter relativ ungebrochen weitergeht
auch in allen altersgruppen und was das
jetzt genau die gründe sind das ist
natürlich eine frage der
bevölkerungsdichte also mecklenburg
vorpommern hat da einen vorteil die sind
dünner besiedelt die haben eher frische
luft die es sitzen einfach da nicht so
eng aufeinander wie groß in großstädten
aber auch in großstädten das ist ja
gelungen die infektionszahlen er zu
senken
und gerade die östlichen bundesländer
sind auch ein bisschen gefährdet weil
die im durchschnitt älter sind in der
bevölkerung haben ja nicht über ein
demografisch gleiche verteilung also
insofern ist das schon ein bisschen
besorgniserregend und wir beobachten das
auch genau und hoffen dass dort auch
eine trendwende
auch bei den jüngeren altersgruppen zu
sehen ist die älteren altersgruppen sind
in vielen bundesländern noch sehr stark
auf dem aufsteigenden ast also fast
überall haben jetzt noch drei anfragen
und jeweils mit der bitte um kurze frage
und kurze antwort ihres marx und sagen
sie noch über die ihrer redaktion dazu
ja hallo hier ist iris marx vom rundfunk
berlin brandenburg
burg ich wollte so nachfragen ob
eventuell hat das hohe niveau der
gemeldeten infektionen eventuell doch
damit noch zusammenhängen können das
gleicht mehr getestet wird oder ist das
einfach jetzt kein argument mehr um das
argument zu entkräften haben wir immer
die ganzen zahlen in unserem
situationsbericht die zeigen sehr schön
dass die rate der infektions positiven
dann nach wie vor steigt ob wir haben
aktuell 93 prozent etwas positiver
also wir können das anhand der zahlen
wirklich ganz gut wieder legen
es gibt auch diese daten von ars und
verschiedene daten wo wir sehen dass die
anzahl der testung altersgruppen auch in
gleichbleibend ist und also nein muss
kurz zu sagen es gibt keinen anlass zu
denken dass es mit einer vermehrten
testung zusammen mit den zahlen die uns
vorliegen wir gehen zu mit der er hat
richtig metropol fm nachrichtenredaktion
erst mal einen schönen tag frau dr
rexroth und herr professor dr wir wissen
dass die gesundheitsämter am wochenenden
dem rk ii nicht komplett alle daten zum
aktuellen stand übermitteln es wird auch
weniger getestet es fällt auf dass seit
einigen wochen von mittwoch auf
donnerstag die infektionszahlen rasant
ansteigen
wir haben von gestern auf heute einen
anstieg von circa 5000 mehr infektionen
wie kann man diese erklären oder wie
kann man dies deuten also es sind nicht
nur dass die gesundheitsämter nicht
übermitteln die allermeisten also alle
bundesländer und die gesundheitsämter
übermitteln schon das sind auch wirklich
die die testungen die über die woche
nicht gleichmäßig verteilt sind und eben
bei den gesundheitsämtern dann ankommt
und es gibt auch unterschiedliche
latenzen also wir sehen dass die schon
großteil
getesteten ihr ergebnis wahrscheinlich
innerhalb eines tages bekommt aber es
staut sich auch immer einiges auf auch
über das wochenende ein rückstau der
dann abgearbeitet wird und dieser
wochenverlauf den haben wir ja über die
gesamte pandemie schon und nicht nur wir
auch andere länder und das ist
verschiedene faktoren das ist auch
inanspruchnahme von bürgern sie müssen
wissen man wird ja nicht sofort so
schwer erkrankt dass man jetzt zu jeder
tages und nachtzeit getestet wird
sondern man es gibt verschiedene test
indikationen es ist die symptomatik dann
gehe ich zum arzt das ist auch ein
ehrlich gesagt normaler verlaufen im
gesundheitswesen dass man dann
wochenrhythmus sieht wir müssen die
letzte frage planet interview herr moore
ja schön
vielen dank zunächst nur ganz kurz ich
würde mich freuen könnten sie nochmal
einmal kurz die zahl sagen wie viel
prozent der bevölkerung in deutschland
der gofit risikogruppe angehören weil
das in der berichterstattung hin und
wieder doch sehr unterschiedlich noch
dargestellt wird und meine eigentliche
frage es wird in den medien ja viel
immer noch natürlich diskutiert über
kroner maßnahmen ich meine jetzt auch
nicht die gespräche mit der sogenannten
corona skeptikern sondern was ich
beispiel eine kritische wortmeldung vom
kölner professor matthias schrappe
neulich im zdf der die grundlage die
datengrundlage der ak ii ihr ja ich
komme so zu meiner frage also es gibt
auch experten meinungen die immer noch
sehr kritisch sind gegenüber
datengrundlage oder maßnahmen nun hat
man sie ja in den letzten monaten nie
gesehen auf solchen podien wo andere
wissenschaftler und experten miteinander
über maßnahmen oder gefährlichkeit
diskutieren warum ist das so
also zunächst die zahl sie fragten also
die zahl die die wir so ungefähr im kopf
sind etwa 30 millionen bundesbürger und
da sind zum einen ich finde ich das
richtig im kopf habe und 23 millionen
die ein bestimmtes alter
also über 60 sind und dann haben wir
natürlich noch die risikogruppen das
sind herz kreislauf und diabetiker unter
anderem und auch menschen mit trisomie
21 haben ein hohes risiko also rund 30
millionen das ist also wirklich eine
große zahl der andere punkt ist der bin
ich mache diese presse briefings und wir
äußern uns als robert koch institut hat
kontinuierlich auch über die situations
berichte und neben ja auch viele von den
kritiken auf also wir haben über die
letzten monate auch immer wieder
kritiken wahrgenommen die wir auch für
berechtigt und haben dann entsprechende
änderungen eingeführt das ist eigentlich
das ganze was ich dazu sagen kann dann
vielen dank und bleiben sie gesund bis
zum ja danke ihnen